[Music]
we're going to go to cliff in
indianapolis in indiana hey cliff how
are you
i'm good happy friday happy friday cliff
what's going on how can george and i
help well i had a question regarding the
envelope system
instead of using a physical envelope and
putting cash into it
is it okay to use a reloadable gift card
that you put money onto
and use that as the envelope well this
is an interesting question
cliff i've actually never heard this ask
but i first want to ask you why you want
to i'm just curious
well um
so our local
marching band
one of their fundraisers is using as a
gift card program
so
i can purchase gift cards and
get reliable gift cards and each time i
put money on it the band earns
money to pay off ban fees
so i actually paid off my sun ban fees
just by
purchasing gas and groceries of gift
cards
interesting
well let me tell you some information
about gift cards and then i'm gonna let
george jump in on this one okay because
this is interesting this is a little
different a little weird which is why i
like it cliff we like weird especially
on fridays i like weird questions i do
okay first first thing you need to know
when you use a card
credit card debit card gift card any
kind of card
your brain does not register that as any
type of significant
pain sacrifice
loss okay research shows this
when you use cash and you actually hand
over dollar bills your brain research
shows that with through mri imaging your
brain registers that as physical pain we
want you to feel a little pain when you
let go of your money because we want you
to know that it's happening it's the
exact opposite effect of when you uh i
was teaching uh dave about this a couple
weeks ago george and cliff about add to
cart sometimes you just add things to
cart because it feels good you don't
really feel the pain of that when you
hit submit
a submit order or you swipe a card you
don't feel it which becomes a problem in
spending because you you spend more than
you realize so that's one thing you need
to know about swiping a card you're not
going to
feel that transaction as much
emotionally as we want you to and you
might be tempted to spend more
the second thing you need to know about
gift cards is 50 of them are never used
50 of gift cards
are never cashed in so
companies love selling gift cards
because they have a massive project
profit margin on them people lose them
and you've probably done it cliff i've
done it i'm guilty of it i've got gift
cards on my desk at home right now that
i haven't used so i i i camp our answer
and that information
and this is kind of like what we were
talking about earlier george where we
were talking about you're not going to
get rich off credit card points oh cash
back cash back we're not in this to play
the game cliff so what i would recommend
here's what i would recommend with that
in mind about we spend more when we
swipe a card we don't use gift cards and
we lose them and we forget their actual
real money with a value what i would
recommend you do if i were you
is i would stick to the plan stick to
the baby steps stick to the cash
envelope system and then if you just
want to give
out of your tithe out of your giving
because you just want to bless your
son's school out of your giving to be
able to pay for their banned things then
do that then it's all kept separate it's
all clean and it's going to keep you on
track i'm just afraid that that's going
to become a slippery slope where you're
swiping right and left you're losing
cards having trouble keeping up with
your your budget and i don't want you to
get i don't want you to get caught up in
that george what would you what would
you say to that yeah i love that
mentality and i'm assuming these are
like reloadable debit cards yeah i don't
i don't know the exact uh parameters of
this but like you're saying christy
there's this element of if you want to
help out you know pay down the ban fees
you can do that with real money too and
you don't have to hope that you're you
know five dollars out of a hundred went
to the band i would just budget for this
as a giving item yeah right and just go
hey what if i could give 20 bucks a
month to help them pay this down because
it's something i'm passionate about so
cliff i love your heart behind this i
want to call that out that that's so
cool that you want to be generous i just
think logically there's a better way to
be generous than by using the gift cards
yeah so you can use a debit card you can
do the cash envelope system whatever
you're gonna do is gonna be best for you
so choose the one that's actually gonna
work that you stick to and then make
this a part of your uh giving as part of
a line item so that you can help the the
band out let's talk about this though
really quickly george because i think
this brings up an interesting point
that's actually bigger than gift cards
and it kind of ties back to what we were
saying at the beginning of the hour of
this idea of credit card rewards
when we get distracted
on our path to managing our money on our
path to building wealth when we get
distracted by the games
games being credit card rewards gift
cards incentives if you you know buy a
pair of shoes someone else gets a pair
of shoes all that's good and fine and
well but if we begin to make purchasing
decisions based on it for example i'm
going to buy some shoes because
someone's going to get shoes
we can get really distracted by the game
and lose sight of what our money is
doing and who's actually in control and
i think the psychology of that is really
fascinating because
you know dave and i were hosting earlier
this week and you'll have people call
sometimes and say well
you mathematically xyz of the baby steps
and they've got some criticisms or some
pushback and the reality is that if we
were if we were doing math we would have
never got ourselves in debt in the first
place
it's it's more about
focus it's more about momentum than it
is about math and so even if yes you
could earn two free dollars for your
son's band in this example cliff or or
or credit card points or get a pair of
jeans or get cash back
we're not doing it for the game and the
game actually will distract you from
what you're trying to do which is get
out of debt and build wealth and and i
know you see this george when you talk
to people because when you get questions
it's often these type of questions where
they're asking about ancillary
uh i'll call them carrots you know like
in in email marketing you give someone a
carrot for their email address it's kind
of like they're holding out these
carrots like do you want this do you
want this free pair of jeans do you want
this
and when we get distracted by the
carrots when we get distracted by these
you know uh incentives
we lose track of what we're trying to do
and we can actually make bad decisions a
little at a time and not realize it oh
yeah and when you're talking about you
know the school making this whole thing
happen of course they're going to say
hey get gift cards because then it makes
it about you right instead of about hey
can we we need money to pay down the
band fees right they're holding out the
offering it played it feels a little bit
different when it says hey buy some gift
cards and you'll help us out at the same
time right and so it kind of makes you
feel like wow i can i can help out and i
can kind of get what i want too right
right oh i've done that before there's a
buy one get when you go well i'm really
getting it for a gift for a friend but
hey i get something out of this too
right so this gamification is all over
the place we're seeing it with
cryptocurrency we're seeing with credit
card rewards we're seeing with
everything out there because there is a
psychology to it where you say christy
but you don't understand i can beat the
game and that's exactly what they want
you to think right right like perfect
they're going to play this game for the
rest of their life and think they're
winning right and the interesting thing
is let's look at the fruit of that
because you are in debt barely getting
by on your bills and they are in
multi-billion dollar buildings
coming up with strategies winning here
right
it's not y'all
we're not the ones winning when we're
playing these games that they come up
with here's here's a good just like
here's a good tip okay
if they came up with a game
it's because they're going to win it
they didn't come up with a game they're
going to lose
they came up with a game that they're
gonna win so if you're playing someone
else's game
you're most likely going to be the one
losing in that scenario whether it's
credit card rewards
airline miles
even gift cards and it's not a bad thing
but but like the the principal here
cliff and for all of you
is keep it clean and separate you could
it doesn't mean we're saying oh don't
support your son's band oh yeah no just
give
when we uh my son started school a
couple weeks ago and the teacher had
like a wish list on amazon and so that
was super fun i knew what she needed
here's all the things i was able to go
on amazon select some items purchase
them and just bring them on the first
day and be like hey just we just want to
donate these to the class it wasn't
fundraisers are not bad y'all they're
not bad at all
but when they distract you from your
financial goals and they lead you to
spend more than you would normally spend
then that's where it becomes a problem
so because it can be a slippery slope
keep it clean and separate
give and be generous we always teach you
guys to give and be generous and and you
can do that whether it's through your
school through your church whatever you
want to do but that's going to keep you
focused on your financial goals and then
you've got a line item for giving and
you've got a line item for groceries and
you've got a line item for everything
else and it's going to keep you on track
which is what you need when you've got
the whole world pulling at you telling
us you to you know buy this and do this
no no we're gonna stay focused on the
goal get out of debt and build wealth
and the best way to do this with the
baby steps and the cash system it's a
great question cliff thank you for
calling